my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them in the
middle of the video hello everybody i
look
so fancy today my god
i'm recording this just after having
recorded something for an award ceremony
i won an award and i'm really excited
about it it's one that's like extra cool
because it's like my whole community won
the award kind of you'll see when it
happens it hasn't happened yet it is not
the game huzz one which i did post about
here if you would like to help me try to
win
uh
top youtuber of the year you can vote
for me i will leave a link in the
description and last year for this same
competition i withdrew myself i asked
them to take me out of the nominations
this year though i'm applying for my
green card and in my category awards
really help so frankly i feel like an
idiot for taking myself out last year
because multiple awards probably would
have been more helpful but that's my
stupid self-righteous ass being like oh
but support the little guy which i still
stand by you know if i get the green
card i will also withdraw forever in the
future but for right now if you would
like to help me not have to go through
the disaster that i did in the whole
nicaragua situation vote for me if you
like no pressure a lot of other cool
creators in there okay it's time for
another q a this one is a gaming q a i
now do personal q a's and gaming q as
separately so if you want to leave
questions in the comments below
you can ask either and i just split up
how i answer them let's do it shall
kevin zero said why do you think ubisoft
won't make a splinter cell it trends
every single time they talk about new
tom clancy games
i'm so glad you asked kevin you do not
want ubisoft to make a splinter cell
game
i stand by it you don't want ubisoft
to make a splash on game
what the current version of ubisoft
would make
would be probably multiplayer games of
service type game there would be micro
transactions and
it wouldn't be heavily stealth because
stealth as a genre
um
is not particularly marketable it means
that there is a barrier for entry that a
lot of people don't want to cross and
i think up until recently probably a lot
of studios felt this way about
horror until resident evil uh both of
the remakes sold so incredibly well i
actually suspect that's why we're
getting dead space is because of the
success
of the resident evil remakes and of
resident evil 7 and 8 which is awesome
but that means that for a big aaa
stealth game to exist of which we don't
really
have any it's kind of just dishonored um
right now if i'm forgetting something
let me know but even dishonored didn't
sell very well um you know thief
obviously was back in the day but point
being just now we do not have any big
stealth franchises in aaa
uh because the the data says that people
don't buy them the sales say that people
don't buy them and uh it means that
they're they're just not gonna make one
it's also you know a lot of ubisoft
games do have light stealth elements as
it stands obviously assassin's creed has
a ton of lighter stealth elements um and
those systems already exist and the way
that ubisoft tends to make games is by
sharing systems across
their massive departments you know they
have multiple teams generally working on
multiple games obviously far cry has
stealth but that means that that system
that already exists in these games
across them um and is shared between the
various ubisoft studios would be the
system that they would put into splinter
cells so
it is not any hardcore stealth by any
means it is not worth it for them
financially to um actually push that
in any one direction uh where
using the current very basic version of
stealth that they have is working better
for them so
ultimately
i think i gave you both responses a if
they were to make a splinter cell and
twitter were to blow up and be excited i
would tell you all that you were being
dumb
you don't want
what ubisoft would currently make
as a spawner cell game
it is not
it just can't exist anymore it's done
it's it sucks but it's done and two yeah
there are a bunch of reasons why they
won't make one trending on twitter
doesn't actually mean anything in the
grand scheme of things you know these
it's just not
not the world we live in it's just not
the world we live in mrp noobster said
what is your least favorite game or
hottest game you've ever played
um the hardest game i ever finished was
ninja gaiden on the original xbox i
slaved at that thing for ages um and
maybe it was just that i was really
young when it came out is why it felt
especially hard
but damn on the hardest difficulty no
less my least favorite game okay this is
not actually true um there are a lot of
games that i don't like i don't like
life is strange that's probably the most
popular franchise that i don't like i've
just never been into like
those kinds of games where you walk
around with a character who's usually
like a little bit rigid and then you
kind of talk to people but it's it's
ultimately just not for me
least favorite game that's really
popular though um and this is a very
complicated opinion
is alan wake
i love remedy
i actually do like alan wake
but alan himself
is just such a big old jerk
when i played it i remember just being
infuriated by how much he hates his wife
why am i putting so much effort into
finding your stupid dumb wife who you
hate it just
i ended up hating him
so intensely and i actually do want to
play the um remaster i think it is
remake i don't remember that just came
out last week
to see if i still feel that way about
him because he drove me nuts he's like
somebody that i love to hate but i still
ultimately did actually really enjoy the
game it is time to talk about keeps for
those who don't know keeps is a
subscription service that focuses on
making it easier and more affordable for
men to treat male pattern baldness
online and i'm certainly not saying that
this is something that you should feel
like you have to do but if you are
insecure about it i have an option for
you keep starts with online doctor
consultations with a real doctor a
licensed doctor will review your
information online and recommend the
right hair loss treatment plan for you
then there is automated shipping and
delivery to your home and it's all at
half the cost of a pharmacy keeps
actually offers generic versions of the
fda approved medications for hair loss
which makes it more affordable and then
step three is taking action tracking
progress and getting support along the
way and one thing that i really love
about keeps is that you have constant
access to your doctor through online
doctor messaging it really is part of
the brand's dna that they are doctor
supported and fda approved which is how
they also know that two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern boldness by the time they're 35
and that the best way to prevent hair
loss is to do something about it while
you still have hair left keeps
treatments typically take between four
to six months to start seeing results so
hey it is time to take action find out
why keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors and why
hundreds of thousands of men trust keeps
for their hair loss prevention if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com alana pierce or
click the link in the description to
receive 50 off your first order that is
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash alana pierce
dodie harry said hey alana i wanted to
know if you had an infinite amount of
money what game would you remake or
approach from a different angle it's an
interesting question i mean my head
jumped straight to not remake but i
would just make
silent hills
i know that it technically doesn't exist
so that doesn't quite apply i've never
really been in the camp of like
desperately wanting remakes though i
definitely like them
and um will play a lot of them but it's
never something i really want to i would
take the money and i would
make something new or a sequel i'm sorry
i cheated i'm sorry hey maybe i throw my
money into cyberpunk or time rather it's
more time but in game development time
equals money i still really liked the
game obviously my background right now
in cyberpunk by by chance
i had a great time playing it on this
beautiful super ultra ride monitor
my my lovely 3080 but it is almost
definitely not the game that the the
developers actually wanted to make it's
the game that they're published and one
of them to get out so i probably would
have given them more time jaffa man said
hey alana with players player characters
in video games do you think it's more
engaging to play as a blank protagonist
who essentially functions as a surrogate
for the player to project themselves
onto for example jack from bioshock or
more clearly or a more clearly defined
character with their own distinct
personality morality and motivation such
as ellie from the last of a series
um i definitely think this is subjective
i don't think there's any good answer to
this like any true answer to this robber
but in my opinion
i find myself more attached to video
game stories where a protagonist
is
a character is not just me i never
really find myself projecting into video
games even when i play rpgs what i try
to do is build a character and then
guess the choices the character would
make
um i don't try to play them like me i
know a lot of people do do that but uh i
have this this running character through
all of the rpgs that i play i try to
make a guy that i've been making for a
really long time who looks very similar
his name is always chaowin
and i kind of know him through all the
games that i've played as ko and which
is every rpg that has a voiceless
protagonist i play as the same dude and
we just go on a lot of adventures
together he's having a great time but i
think generally
you know empathy is a really strong part
of video games it is um
i don't know how else to phrase that
genuinely like one of the strongest
parts of the medium versus all other
mediums is the ability to make the
people consuming the entertainment media
feel a level of empathy because they are
actually
interacting they'll at least they feel
like they're interacting
with um
whatever is happening with the other
characters with with the world around
them and so i think
when that empathy comes in the form of
you playing as someone and you doing the
things that they need to do um with
their context with that world or with
the other characters it means a lot more
if joel from the last of us
were voiceless throughout the entirety
of that first game
you wouldn't have the contacts with
sarah and you wouldn't know how his
relationship with ellie is developing
and you can't develop a relationship the
way that a character like joel can i'm
glad that both exist though i think that
like i'm glad the zelda series which to
me has always been about gameplay more
so than story i'm so sure some zelda
fans don't agree with that i'm glad link
doesn't talk i think that
i find those worlds much more
interesting
so i don't want one to exist versus the
other but yeah i feel like i find it
more engaging on a story level
if the player character is a character
and not just my projections milkshake
mustaches
milk steak it just says milk mustaches
why did i put a
milk steak in there
uh they said do you ever gain well buzz
and if so what do you sip on are you any
good at getting well drunk um
yeah so i don't
drink while gaming but i will game while
drunk if that makes sense so i don't
ever drink by myself i don't ever drink
like in small groups it's only ever
really like a social thing if i go to a
party or i go to a bar or something then
i'll have a drink um but then sometimes
like when i'm home later i will drink i
very often go back to sakura so i play
the game on pc but started it again on
xbox and i feel like
you could tell if i'm drunk by seeing
when i played sakura i know that's
insane that's an insane choice of the
game but for some reason if i'm drunk i
want to play sakura i don't know why so
i'm very very very slowly getting
through the xbox version of the game
while drinking i have a drunk sakura
game play up on my channel it's very
weird i played a lot of halo drunk but
i've never actually been very good at
halo um
kind of bad at halo despite the amount
of hours that i've put into halo and my
love for the franchise i've never been
very good at halo multiplayer but my
go-to alcoholic beverage is a vodka soda
which is very boring but my hangovers
started getting real bad when i hit like
25 and i mean i'm only 28 now
but they'll last like two days
vodka sodas at least i feel like i'm
getting water and it helps
otherwise i would just quit drinking
neal metal said what do you think of
rockstar removing the gta trilogy
um i also covered this on tick tock look
at me doing news
so yeah um
rockstar announced the re-release
remaster of the grand theft auto trilogy
which i absolutely love i still have
like this black paper box that i got
those in when i was i don't know 12 11 i
don't i don't know
um
of gta 3 which damn i love san andreas
which damn i love and vice city which i
never finished because i actually had a
game breaking bug
where uh at a certain mission no matter
what um i would try to go to this
particular door that i had to go through
and i would fall through the map
so i never finished that game and
this seems like a great way for me to
play it again so i'm pretty stoked about
them re-releasing it um but yes as part
of that they are removing the existing
versions from digital stores which
is undoubtedly shady like i feel like
there's no question about that they are
clearly removing the old versions to
make you buy the new versions and i
guess you could make some cases for oh
well they want you to play the more
optimized versions but then why wouldn't
they just give you a
cheap upgrade or a free upgrade
yeah it sucks um but i also wouldn't
blame rockstar for that i would think
that that is a 2k initiative sorry a
take two initiative it's confusing when
2k is also on the take two take two
rock stars publisher there's also just
all this conversation around that but
again i spoke about it on tick tock it's
so weird i only just made a tech talk
i'm very new to this i don't know what's
happening
people are like oh they'll never release
gta 6 stop working on remosters these
are fully different teams this
i promise you that them re-releasing the
gta trilogy and this definitive edition
i think it's called
has zero bearing on gta 6 which i
promise you is in development and is
going to come out
yes they keep re-releasing gta 5 but
that's because it's one of the most
profitable games ever made and continues
to be and it's easier to do that but it
doesn't actually take anything away from
gta 6. if anything the more money
rockstar makes from gta online more they
can put into a potential gta 6 campaign
which jesus if they get rid of that i'll
be sad i mean dan howes are leaving
it's scary thought but no i i
have zero doubt honestly gta 6 is being
made clearly from their track record
uh rockstar are making bigger and better
games every step of the way i mean even
the leap between gta 5
and red dead redemption 2 is really
significant and i don't think that
they're going to release anything unless
they are happy with it that's that's the
thing you can pretty much guarantee with
that studio is
give them time and they will make
something incredible and i have no doubt
about that
which is the thing about like discourse
that gets kind of exhausting is that we
get mad when somebody releases a game
too soon a la cyberpunk but then when
they take their time we get mad because
they're taking their time
you know what i'm saying games are hard
to make
and also they had so many reports of
crunch that
hopefully this means that that's less of
an issue greg alex said what's a game
you should have played by now and it's a
sin that you haven't played it
uh minus final fantasy vii um mine is
chrono trigger i don't remember where i
said this recently but it's definitely
chrono trigger i know that i need to
play chrono trigger i barely even know
anything about it so
i
will
get through my backlog one step at a
time
jeff deleon said while you're awesome
gig at santa monica studios prevent you
from making cameos in other games i'll a
cyberpunk no it doesn't prevent me from
cameos doesn't prevent me from even
riding on other games i have
uh written on
two other games um
while at
santa monica studio so yeah i still have
voice cameos coming up i've got two
really exciting ones that are still
probably pretty far from releasing but
two that i
am very stoked about i'm getting better
at it still learning still learning
still not a great voice actor but we're
getting there
alrighty everybody that is it from me
today um if you want to ask questions
for the next q a it'll be up in two
weeks time and it will be my personal q
a but you can still ask gaming questions
in this one and i'll keep pulling them
from different comments sections
basically i'll source them anyway but
yes the next one will be a personal q a
so you can ask about anything other than
video games you can ask tvs movies books
whatever you like and i will answer
those in a couple of weeks a huge thank
you again to keeps for sponsoring this
video
i will see you guys next time